but uh yeah humanity is more and more
[__] every year yeah I can see why the
older generation like you know keeps
repeating that yeah but this has been
like a phenomenon for for um centuries
where the previous generation deem the
coming generation to be oh for sure but
I feel like this time they're on to
something no no you feel that cuz it's
your every generation felt like that
Joey yeah there's literally like
newspaper articles of like the early
1800s being like these these new
generations have no manners they can't
can't function in walking around showing
ankle yeah and then you know they then
the next Generation does the same thing
this is a Perpetual thing where
obviously the newer generation are going
to evolve you know and it's up to us to
evolve evolve you mean grow up no evolve
like what they what their tastes are
Pokemon like our dad wasn't jacking
human is evolving our wasn't jacking
into a Tanger you know what I mean
that's a new that's a new development
Jackhammer phone holders that's a new
generation they're evolving but I will
say yeah yes you know definitely every
generation for the past couple of
centuries have been saying that about
the newer generations for sure but I
feel no you're falling into the Trap Jo
feel like we're the different one the
next one really is [__] no but like we
were talking about like the the uh you
know lessening of optimism in the newer
generation right and like how everyone
is becoming more doomish I think so like
has that happened in previous
generations Maybe not maybe they have
but maybe not to the same extent as it
is now because we're running into I
actually feel like things like
Millennials we started that trend
just kind of like went with the
depression Trend and just like actually
we can do it better than you we ran J
could War I'm sure there was somebody in
1910 they were like oh boy G in America
I can't wait to join the job market next
year boom Great Depression no jobs for
you everyone is starving four year three
or four years this [__] lasts for yeah
I'm sure they would probably think well
we had it [__] bad obviously but like
you know say for like say for like our
generation right like millennials yeah
were we was it so much of a common uh
like uh idea between like people of Our
Generation I guess the newer generation
to be like as like doomy or sad about
our future compared to like this newer
generation well also we didn't have to
[__] kill each other you know you you
talked to the older generation and they
went through [__] several world like
several Wars but I'm I'm comping and
like they they look at our generation
I'm like what the [__] do you have war
with clearly yeah clearly talking about
this newer generation now right like the
newest generation like why is there
suddenly so much of a bigger shift I
think what [__] uh I think there's
just a lot more shared experience and
also you know there was definitely like
houses were and stuff like that house
house rent and whatnot was definitely
Rising like 20 years ago but obviously
for sure there wasn't as many people
talking about it online uh and arguing
about it also you have to bear in mind
that like like 20 30 years ago it was
kind of seems like a bad thing to be
like I can't afford this or like this
might money nowadays it's like hey can
you also not afford rent I can't afford
rent completely anecdotal because I have
no evidence to back this up but this
yeah this is all pure speculation like
for me but uh I think just just existing
has never been harder yeah just just
just the act of existing you know um you
know maybe that you know that you had
some bad times like the Great Depression
obviously bad times
as we like the big S as we like to call
it the big sagge okay we should have the
Great Depression no we shouldn't have
that well should call it something
better not the Great Depression the big
sag yeah we we call it the big S if we
have another one we should the big sge
we'll call the big sge the big sagge of
the 2030s yeah it's a 100e cycle do when
did they coinin the term Great
Depression was it during the time or it
was it was happening in the 30s right
well this this is like a good question
of like did they call it um cuz it was
called the Great War World War I and
they asked when did they start referring
to it as World War I yeah and it wasn't
until I think a lot long
after probably not until World War II
right but I think it was sometime after
as well it wasn't immediately after they
weren't like I remember one this is the
sequel yeah I think it was uh there was
a good video about it I can't remember
what it's called right uh but I mean
that doesn't [__] matter it's stupid
stupid figuring out when [__] was named
but like you I wonder well what what are
they going to name it's based on a book
called The Great Depression by Hoover oh
okay what are they going to name Co
times reckon when historians look back
and
think pandemic I don't know this is this
this isn't the first pandemic we've been
through though right this is this is the
first Global pandemic in a very long
time I mean there was the Black Death as
well but that was only in Europe only
that only wiped out like a third a third
of humanity if you remember that like
this the first pandemic that's been
available uh that's very easily spread
in the modern travel era where people
can just get like I can get to I can be
in Australia tomorrow yeah it was kind
of difficult to travel in the 13 back
then they like I think in like uh in I
think one of the wars there was like
uh uh there was a kind of influenza that
was that was wreaking havoc yeah um and
but that was localized to Europe at that
time right CU there was some people like
flying all over the [__] place
spreading it to their like whoever and
everyone um so yeah it's I mean it's
interesting I think it's it's it's weird
cuz like I obviously we we're in very
good Financial places but I still feel
like holy [__] like I buying a house is
still a hard thing to do oh yeah scary
like crazy I'm like oh my god when I
look back at brochures they're like yeah
we'll ship you a house and you build it
for for $110,000 I'm like what it's a
giant Lego set yeah they used to sell
made to order houses they would just
send you the parts and you build it this
is the thing in America I thought was
crazy that's so cool we can't do that
now that's insane uh yeah those made to
order houses that uh you could that were
in America uh that's prefab but I think
that's what probably come up you could
could literally get sent and they would
send you all the things in like crates
and you would presumably just build it
oh my God this is like Ikea nightmare
mode this is your final this is your
final boss after this is what the Lego
training up with the Legos and this is
the final boss at this mail order house
it's beautiful that's a yeah that's a
nice house holy [__] yeah obviously even
even with inflation it was still way
more affordable than houses nowadays
yeah gez um it's crazy though but that's
back when everyone just I guess somehow
knew how to build a house yeah I oh yeah
it was
$2,000 in uh 19 something which even
with inflation wouldn't come close to 19
1960 16 what's what's $2,000 in 1916 in
today's money could you have a look two
million just type it in there's like
calculators to tell you no I've I've
been recommended more and more videos of
just people living on the road in
[__] Vans and Caravans and [__] that
feels like like a kind of subconscious
like struggle answer to this world we
live in where it's like I can't [__]
pay $31,000 that's nothing yeah holy
[__] the [__] cars are more expensive
than yeah I mean I could you guys ever
do that like just pack up okay number
one I find this concept really
interesting because I don't know how
many other countries you can get away
with doing this aside from America
because it's funny cuz I've actually uh
met people that have done that life uh
when I went back to Wisconsin this year
uh Sydney's like extended Friendship
Circle had like some new people join
and they had had a year or maybe two
years just literally they sold
everything they owned put everything
into a van and just traveled the road
and just lived on the road for two years
and after two years they just hit
Wisconsin and we're like I think we've
had enough of traveling let's just uh
just get onart that's badass it's
[__] badass but holy [__] it made me
realize how op America is because I
couldn't like imagine like traveling
imagine England in a week yeah yeah
imagine doing that in England or some
[__] cuz they were like yeah we started
off in like West Coast went up north
went all the way to Alaska for like a
bit like drove back down and I'm like yo
you drive through Canada as well yeah
I'm like yo that sounds [__] badass I
me we we kind of in a sense did like a a
light version of that on the US tour
right like we were we were in that bus
for 50 days I I don't I don't think I
can do and considering that I enjoyed
the tour the most I could probably do
it I like I need to be stationary to do
anything like I like having a Zone my
little safe save point where I'm like
this is where I like subconsciously this
is where I clock in and out of life
right I need that but wouldn't you say
that that's the little personal van
personal vehicle that you have no cuz
you're never truly stationary right
you're always subject to someone else's
rules right if you park in this place
all right what how can you park here or
what can you do yeah if you put it in
the middle of the [__] desert okay
but then what if something goes wrong
you know what if you pop a tire in the
middle of the [__] desert for for
some reason you're driving I don't know
there's there's so many factors so
that's that's like that's like city boy
mentality all the way cuz I actually I
absolutely agree I would be terrified
about I care too much about everything
that could go wrong and I think you have
you cannot care about [__] going wrong
if you want to live that lifestyle you
need to like almost disregard oh how am
I going to shower how am I going to do
laundry like I'm sure then they work it
out right because they're they're like
but to me I wouldn't even want to embark
on this unless I figured it all out and
I wouldn't even want to go on it unless
I figured out the route which is like
psychotic and I I just can't do it I
just to me it wouldn't yeah so you don't
have a manly urge to drop everything and
just build a cabin in the woods and just
[__] survive on survive on the
Wilderness I the first thing I'm doing
when I retire bro well I like too many
of the modern comforts you know I'm only
human I like a lot of them and I I
that's how it is and I think there's
nothing wrong with that there totally I
[__] love a good meal and I love a
good coffee that's what matters most
ain't nothing wrong with that dog that's
that's nothing wrong with that as all
but the more go the more the more I grow
older the more I'm like yeah that manly
urge is real I don't know if it's an
actual manly urge but it's just an urge
I just is there more so an urge that you
want to have that life or that you are
you are not content with what is
currently happening in life and the the
cycle you're in no I think it's more so
like I am I'm very much you know I the
urge is in the future for me like I I'm
completely content with my life now and
I'm very happy with where I am now in my
life and I would like to continue it for
as long as possible but I know there's
going to be a point where I'm probably
going to hit a wall where I'm just like
I need some change in my life cheese mhm
you know or cheese you know or cheese
you know I need I need some change in my
life I need some kind of radical change
in my life whether it be for my mental
health or whether it be just like if I'm
still doing a creative job you know it's
always a nice change of pace to like
switch your environment right it's just
nice I I don't know I like the thought
of just removing all complexities from
your life I mean I guess I've done it
once before uh but that was like a very
very very extreme version of just
removing all external complexities this
is kind of like a lighter version where
you're kind of just doing your own thing
you're living to uh you're just living
man you're just you're just living out
there I'd be happy like camping for a
month that'd be fun yeah the joy yeah
the joy I get from making a fire and
cooking a meal on that fire yeah but
think about it if you lived in a van you
could do that anywhere you want whenever
you want yeah as long as you're not in
someone's backyard you can do that
wherever you want bro that America has
so much land man [__] yeah but I I'm
like okay I'd rather just travel around
it and I don't know when I see these r
videos sometimes it makes me depressed
why cuz I I look at it and I'm like wow
you don't have an espresso machine you P
you can you can install one in the van
that's the first thing a lot better than
others but someone will show their van
and it's like it just looks really sad
it also looks lonely okay there are
there are different levels like I've
also I've also seen [__] Justin
Bieber's tour of us that's see that's
where I'm like all right let's do this
let's do this van like can you can you
show Justin Bieber custom two of us this
is where I can do the van like all this
is like that's not a van at that point
but I saw this one where this woman had
to like she was like I'm going to shower
now what the [__] Jesus Christ I I think
I can do the that's a hotel room I can
do that's a moving hotel room yeah I can
do the van life oh if it was this I
could leave in that for the rest of my
life like there there's like so many
levels to it but it's basically what
you're comfortable with because I like
I've been recommended every level which
includes just guys who are living out of
their cars in New York living out living
out of their Mini Coopers no no no like
literally just living out of their cars
and he's like here's my apartment tour
and like I think my favorite comment is
just like [__] will be homeless
in New York but be like but the food is
really good
though that's true that's
true [__] will live literally
live out of a shoe box pay 3K forent off
the most about New York when they
[__] tell me about their water I
don't give a [__] about your water and
why it makes bread taste better stop
[__] telling no one cares about your
[__] water I I haven't heard about
this New York water thing oh my God if
you talk to New York they don't shut the
[__] up about it you're like I New
Yorkers like we got the best bread in
all of America I'm like it's not that
good it's it's you think it's better
than it is like no no our water is
scientifically proved it's the best
water in all this and it's like no I
don't think so I disagree
like scientifically and I'm like I I I
have you been to Europe no but New York
we got it's like shut up shut up shut up
shut
up damn did you notice this when we were
in New York [__] will never shut up
by that damn water and white makes bread
taste perfect never I never heard a New
Yorker talking about their water maybe I
got lucky I I find it Charming I
summoned them in the comments no I I
find I found it Charming at first Cal
yeah until you literally can't tell them
their bread is not the best in the world
they W they won't they won't take it KH
it's like it's like getting yungo J bro
it's Charming at first and then it gets
[__] annoying you can't them their
Bread's not the best in the world they
they lose it they like they like
self-destruct of Rage we got the delies
though I know you you you go to a lot of
parts in America and you know some parts
are more like the others New York is one
of like one of the cities that I think
has its own kind of culture which I
think absolutely which I think it it has
a real unique identity to it which is
more than I can say for a lot of cities
uh In America which is something I
really really respect about New York and
New Yorkers as well which is like an
identity you know I kind of like dig
that okay but like do you think that the
whole van life stuff because I there's
so many van life influences which uh my
brother's actually been inspired by oh
yeah he's got his own van oh [__] um and
he travels around it's fine it's nice
it's cozy dude my dream car is a comi
van oh really yeah Volkswagen kby van I
really want one what I I don't know what
he has but it's it's good uh and um I
for him it was like okay well he'll work
on it a bunch but my my dad helped
mostly but uh if I tell him that he'll
get annoyed but true um but like for him
it's like okay that's more of a like a
okay we live in this place we have a
good time then maybe we do like weekl
long trips in this thing yeah and for
that I was like that sounds like a
really healthy way but when I'm like
you're living out of it and then I see
some of these videos and I'm like is
this just like I don't know does it feel
like the last optionz it's like I don't
know what to do like I'm to me some of
these some of these videos just felt
really sad when I watched them why sad
cuz they just look lonely they look so
lonely maybe maybe they like that maybe
they like that like solidarity and this
one video this one person they even said
that they were like yeah the hardest
thing about doing van life is uh you
know it's the fact that you don't really
get to talk with people or meet with
people cuz you're always in a new place
but look I installed a new shower in my
van and I was like whoa whoa whoa but
it's not but glossed over the most
important pressing factor ofbe maybe
it's my perspective but I always looked
at these like people who live out of
these Vans and go traveling the country
or the world or whatever I've always
seen it as like well isn't the point to
like living in a van so that you can go
see these new places and meet these new
people like isn't the social aspect
really tied in with your lifestyle yeah
but I guess some people maybe they
didn't think about because a lot a lot
of people never think about social life
or being social it's always an
afterthought for everyone right yeah
maybe they jumped on the van like they
like I'm just going to [__] ran
everyone maybe they're We Wrong how do I
maintain friendships here have exist
timately we're all human and we all need
to have friends yeah social creatures
even the most like even the biggest
introverts will crave social interaction
every now and again because that is just
how we survived and how we've evolved
and how our brains are on the meat yeah
I couldn't I couldn't break it apart you
know it's it's it's uh and that to me
would be the the biggest thing that i'
miss is like how the [__] do I have any
meaningful conversations or connections
to people while I'm in a van yeah I'm
not the same place but that's like why
wouldn't I just stay
home yeah but you can travel the world
and also also sometimes you know I know
I know it's not a big deal but I I feel
bad when some of the van people I saw
this dude who had like three pets and I
was like I'm like maybe you shouldn't
have three pets in a van I'm like uh I
know I know you canop the pets get to uh
[__] to go crazy but I'm like man I
feel bad when it depends what kind of
pet as well yeah yeah I don't know yeah
if it's a [__] if it's three dogs
then I don't think it's anything wrong
with that yeah yeah yeah but I guess it
also depends on type of dog as well I
guess yeah